I'm Caroline Jones and I work on the
research team at today's homeowner
Nevada specifically is sitting right
below the national average price per
square foot the average is 158 dollars
per square foot and Nevada is right
below it at 156 per square foot it looks
like it's still cheaper in the west save
for California to build your own home
can you talk about that
yeah it's very interesting um the map
that we have in our study found
um it depicts our data and it shows that
only eight states out of the United
States it's cheaper to build a home
rather than to buy one and other than
Florida which is in the East the rest of
all of these states where it's cheaper
are the West to the Midwestern states so
we see that Nevada and Colorado Utah
Arizona Washington Oregon Idaho they are
all cheaper to build a home than to buy
one which is a very interesting fact to
think about today's homeowner has been a
leading expert in the Home Improvement
industry for 25 years and we really
strive to help homeowners make smart
decisions buying
renting and financially so we really
hope that our studies will be able to
provide provide helpful information for
people looking to buy their first home
move to a different location or by their
first apartment as well so we are really
looking forward to helping a lot of
homeowners around the country